[Applause]
[Music]
italy
is known as the sick man of europe along
with greece it is the only eurozone
country that is poorer today than it was
20 years ago that's right it's estimated
that every italian citizen has lost an
average of 73
000 euros since 1999. all this is
surprising if we take into account that
in the 1990s italy was a driving force
in europe take a look at this graph
[Music]
in 1992 italians were even richer than
the british these were the years when
milan was the undisputed fashion capital
fiat cars dominated the markets and
singers like laura pozzini filled
stadiums all over europe however all of
that is water
under the bridge to give you a
comparison in the 90s italy's economy
grew by 38
but in the last 10 years it's only grown
by 2.5
on top of this we have to add the public
debt italy is the fifth most indebted
economy in the world
to give you an idea italian debt is
almost double the entire gdp of a
country like brazil no matter which
ranking we look at
italy is the anti-sweden that is when
you look at rankings of anything related
to economics education or any other
scale sweden is the country that is
usually in the positive zone meanwhile
in any of these same rankings italy is
usually at the other extreme
all of this was the situation before the
pandemic and as you can imagine
after the pandemic the situation is much
worse italy was one of the first
countries to report cases of coronavirus
outside of china and it's also been one
of the most affected but wait
a minute because problems in italy never
come alone
[Music]
italy's post-pandemic recovery
endangered by political crisis
expansion so what political crisis does
the news headline refer to the truth is
that what is known in the rest of the
world as a political crisis is pretty
much just
business as usual in italy and yes if
the italian economy is a disaster it is
largely due to its politicians
few countries have such schizophrenic
politics as italy let me give you an
example the normal process in any
democracy is that a candidate wins the
election and governs for like
four or five years right sure there can
be motions of censure or early elections
but usually that's pretty unusual italy
is the opposite it is almost
impossible to appoint an italian prime
minister who ends up finishing his term
to give you an idea
the average government in italy lasts
two years in the last decade alone
italians have had seven different prime
ministers so
being an italian politician is a
stressful job but there is no shortage
of jobs few countries have more
politicians than italy to give you an
idea if we add up all the members of the
italian parliament and senate we have
951 parliamentarians in other words
italy has more parliamentarians than the
united states or the entire
european union however in today's video
we're going to focus on one specific
italian politician who am i talking
about let me introduce to you
super mario mario draghi was sworn in as
prime minister on saturday to lead a
unity government
13th of february 2021 reuters that's
right italy got a new prime minister in
2021 but he's not just any politician we
are talking about mario draghi if you're
watching this video from anywhere in
europe you're likely to have this
gentleman's autograph
in your pocket we are talking about the
former president of the european central
bank the man we all know by the name
super mario and why do we call him super
mario because he is rumored to have
super powers and now you're probably
thinking really what kind of super
powers does he have well
it's the power of words pay attention to
this sentence
within our mandate within our mandate
the ecb is ready to do whatever it takes
to preserve the euro
and believe me it will be enough
[Applause]
and obviously being italian he mostly
said that sentence with his hands but
days after saying it europe ended the
entire debt crisis just like that of
course
all of this has an economic explanation
which we'll talk about in another video
but the remains the legendary figure the
legend of the man whose words
served to save the euro and the question
now is can super mario save italy from
its politicians can italy get out of its
ongoing crisis how will it do it today
we're going to answer all these
questions but first let's take a look at
some history
[Music]
the zakirow years before i go any
further i think i know what you're all
wondering just where grant did you get
this
cool dinosaur juice visualpolitik
t-shirt from this is just what it seems
exclusive visualpolitik merchandising i
mean exclusive we're talking about mugs
and t-shirts with original designs
created by ourselves and if you're
wondering so where can i get my hands on
it well the truth is that we've decided
that visualpolitik merchandising will
never be for sale there is only one way
to get it and that's by supporting us on
patreon if you subscribe to level 3 or
above on our patreon program we will
send the merch to your home at least
twice a year that's right we want these
products to be reserved only for our
die-hard visualpolitik fans
also have you become a level 3 patron
you'll receive our weekly snapshot with
news and analysis you won't find
anywhere else not to mention
cool t-shirts like this but now let's
get on with our story those of you in a
certain age who grew up in europe will
remember the golden age of italian music
the time when zucchero sang with freddie
mercury laura possibly was on every
radio station when we all had pictures
of sabrina salerno in her class folder
well i mean i didn't i'm a nice young
man but i'm sure
some people did
[Music]
this was a golden era for italy the
italians were as rich as the french and
the germans in fact back then they were
investing in eastern europe like there
was no tomorrow cities like prague have
lots of buildings owned by italians but
that's another story the question is why
was italy so rich there are many reasons
but mainly
italy's wealth was due to this
[Music]
here you see the value of the former
italian currency the italian lira
against the us dollar as you can see the
italian lyra was a very
weak currency and what did that mean
exactly well it was continuously
devaluing for example in 1976 one dollar
was worth 850 lira 14 years later it was
worth more than 2
000 and you're probably thinking so what
does all this mean for growth for
example imagine an italian clothing
manufacturer selling to the united
states if the lyra depreciates the
manufacturer receives more lira for the
same amount of dollars
thanks to this it can lower the price in
dollars and be more competitive
normally devaluing the currency
increases our country's exports at least
in the short term so what is the
downside of devaluing well
in the long term that same clothing
manufacturer has no incentive to invest
for example any machine purchased abroad
will be more expensive for them
than its competitors
so what's the conclusion of this italy
became the china of europe from the 70s
until the 90s it filled the world's
markets with low-cost products they made
the same but cheaper so what went wrong
well it's easy to be the china of europe
and china is not yet in the
international market but that all
changed in 2001.
[Music]
china joins the wto at last bbc
as you can imagine if your main
competitive advantage is price good luck
competing with china's low wages
virtually overnight italian trinkets had
to compete with chinese trinkets so
what could italy do at that point
devalue the lira again well
no they couldn't and why not because of
this europe also has a common currency
the euro our money
and just like that italy lost all its
competitive advantage since then italy
has not been able to get back on its
feet and so now you're probably thinking
so
should they get out of the euro perhaps
the question should be is it possible
for italy to be competitive without
manipulating its currency for example
why doesn't italy innovate i mean do
they just do pizza and pasta and then
stop let me give you a fact
investment in research and development
europe invests on average 2.13
of gdp into research and development in
italy it's only 1.29
no matter which education ranking we're
looking at italy is the worst performing
country in other words for those of you
watching this video from the united
states italy is the mississippi of
europe and you will say but where did
they go wrong
why are they so far behind we're gonna
check that out now
[Music]
the land of bureaucracy two professions
abound in italy footballers
and models i'm kidding politicians and
civil servants and we're not talking
about just any civil servants according
to the imf italian civil servants earned
more than their counterparts in private
enterprise in fact they end practically
the same as their german counterparts
even though germany
is a richer country than italy and it's
practically impossible to fire them if
you're watching this from a country like
say spain you'll be like yeah you can't
fire civil servants that's just the way
it is if you're watching this from
anywhere that's
normal you'll say what the privileges of
civil servants reach such an extent that
even now after the corona virus many
italians are beginning to protest
against them italians take aim at the
bureaucratic bourgeoisie foreign policy
but
is that really the reason for italy's
problems do civil servants get paid too
much no that's not the worst problem the
worst problem is
they have bulletproof contracts they're
completely inefficient
italy sinks into the pit of
uncompetitiveness
abc.es for example imagine we have a
company in denmark and we have to sue a
customer who does not pay
what they owe well an average of a
little under a year in denmark the court
will resolve the case
in italy the same procedure would take
three years
whatever the procedure everything in
italy takes two or three times longer
than
any other european country from paying
taxes to setting up a company
but wait a minute because the problem is
not merely that the bureaucracy is
inefficient the problem is that
bureaucracy
is everywhere and here i'm going to give
you an example that we experienced here
at visualpolitik a few years ago
for a while we had an italian woman on
the team who worked as a documentary
filmmaker this woman wants people to
also work with the big italian
newspapers such as liberatsonne well
in order to work as a journalist in
italy you need a permit that's right you
need to get your journalist license
and to get that you need to prove
experience as a journalist well no
matter how much we signed all kinds of
documents saying that she had worked a
visual politic the italian authorities
didn't recognize their experience after
all
youtube since when can a youtuber be
considered a media outlet
to give you an idea there is regulation
with all the steps you have to follow to
open a media outlet in case anyone is
thinking about it
no italy is not exactly famous for
having media that are international
benchmarks
[Music]
so what's the conclusion of all this in
italy it's very difficult to set up a
small business innovate and grow
bureaucracy has become an invisible wall
that makes many businesses end up in the
underground economy
while germany has thousands of
medium-sized companies that are world
leaders and their specific niche italy's
products sector is divided into two
groups large companies such as fiat
group or the energy company eni which
are becoming less and less competitive
and family-owned
micro smes in other words italy has been
in free fall for decades and the
coronavirus has been the final nail in
the coffin the question now is what can
they do to start growing can mario
draghi also known as super mario
really turn things around well we're
gonna check that out now
the new marshall plan so we're back to
today's main character
super mario who served as the president
of the european central bank from 2012
to 2019.
his most important legacy was to save
the euro thanks to the massive purchase
of sovereign debt and the injection of
liquidity into the banks but we will all
remember him for the phrase that changed
european finances overnight his new
magic words were these
[Music]
today we have as did the governments of
the immediate post-war period
the possibility or rather than
responsibility to start a new
reconstruction mario draghi
but what exactly do these words mean
it's quite simple after the second world
war the united states sent
huge amounts of money to italy to
rebuild this was called the marshall
plan
right now in 2021 we're talking about a
new marshall plan the difference is the
money's not coming from washington but
from
brussels and so draghi's first priority
is deciding what to do with all this
money check this out
italian parliament approved draghi's
recovery plan el economista and so now
you're probably wondering so what does
this plan consist of we are talking
about no less than 222 billion euros
that's 13
of italy's gdp almost all of this money
is going to be used to build
infrastructure mainly in the south it
includes the modernization of railroads
roads etc but not
only that now we've realized that
italy's problem is not that it has old
trains italy's problem is the size and
functioning of its state and that's why
draghi has been innovative about
something he wants to fire
almost a third of his colleagues take a
look at this
[Music]
italians have voted in a referendum to
cut the size of the country's parliament
by more than a third bbc
this may seem a populist measure what's
more we cannot really say that this cut
is a dragging measure either in fact it
was discussed even before super mario
came to power but
the truth is that italy has more
deputies and senators than any other
country as a comparison
spain with 50 million inhabitants has a
parliament of 350 deputies italy with 60
million inhabitants has a parliament of
630 deputies
to give you an idea this reduction of
deputies will mean a saving of 1 billion
euros over 10 years but this measure
goes beyond money
maybe now it'll be easier to reach a
consensus maybe this will allow draghi
to i don't know
finish his first term remember after all
we're still talking about italy what in
any other country would be called a
political crisis or impeachment is just
business as usual in italy clearly they
need to change their political structure
[Music]
is this the best way to do it only time
will tell but draghi's plan does not
stop there he wants to lower taxes
and above all reduce bureaucracy the
italian plan also seeks to modernize
public administration which includes
reducing civil trial times by 40
and criminal trials by 25 as well as
promoting competition and putting an end
to monopolistic practices who will also
be cuts in bureaucracy but it's still
too early to know how the cuts will be
put into action
for the moment we can only say that
super mario magic is starting to work
with draghi the vaccination campaign has
been accelerated they hope to have
80 of the population vaccinated by
september super mario has already
completed his first 100 days in office
with an approval rating of more than 50
which in italy is like a big deal
however the hardest part of his mandate
is still to come if you think cutting a
bureaucracy in a country with millions
of well-off civil servants will not
bring protests well then you don't
really know italy so now it's over to
you do you think mario draghi will be
able to put an end to the sluggish
italian bureaucracy or maybe the italian
bureaucracy will defeat super mario and
his legend
can italy get out of two decades of
ongoing crisis
you can leave me your answer in the
comments below as always don't forget
that here on visualpolitik we have new
videos every week so subscribe to this
channel and hit the little bell down
there so you don't miss any of our
updates if you liked this video please
give it a thumbs up
and i'll see you next time